le vent et la pluie ne les ont pas
découragés une cinquantaine de cyclistes
au lieu des 150 inscrits est venu ce
dimanche 27 septembre sur la ligne de
départ pour participer au 5e grand prix
cycliste de montigny et l'épreuve prévue
initialement au printemps cette journée
à une journée humide non prévus pour en
plus remercier les courageux qui sans
lui ce matin
de bonne heure pour venir faire une
course sous la pluie et dans le vent
mais ça fait partie de répartie du lit
métier de coureur cycliste
les cours de 18 à 50 ans réalisé 26
tours de 3 km pour un total de 78 km à
la fin de l'épreuve les organisateurs
avaient bloqué plusieurs rues de
montigny le bretonneux pour créer un
parcours atypique pour les sportifs gros
peloton parce que les routes sont larges
on sait relativement plat et la grosse
difficulté c'est la montée de nicolas
bour
suivant le sens du vent s'ils vont
pousser les coureurs c'est facile s'il
est dans l'otan c'est difficile cette
édition 2020 a permis à un coureur de
montigny le bretonneux de s'illustrer
romain bardet homonyme du célèbre
coureur français devenu le premier
sportif du club a remporté ce grand prix
une nouvelle édition sera programmée
l'année prochaine les organisateurs
espèrent cette fois ci l'organiser au
printemps